all right I had a Michigan woman
convicted of arson and the murder of her
husband is telling her story for the
first time in a 48 hours mystery
authorities say let Linda's termers at
her home on fire to kill her husband
Todd and then ran him over with a man
when he escaped the flames she was
sentenced to life in prison
fermer later convinced a judge she did
not get a fair trial and was released
now the Michigan Attorney General is
fighting to reinstate her conviction
Erin Moriarty of 48 hours investigates
on the afternoon of January 7 2007 the
day her house went up in flames
Linda Sturmer says she was doing laundry
in the basement when she heard her
husband Todd let out a scream and ran
upstairs there just seemed to be fire
all over in the living room I could not
have gotten over to Todd because there
was fire between the two of us she
panicked she says and escaped through
the front door with no shoes or
cellphone my first thought was to get
out Todd's gonna get out she says that
she was about to drive off for help Todd
did get out alive and that she tried to
help him he's jumping around and he's
patting himself he's his skin is burnt
terribly I can't touch him and so I get
back in the van
and I lost sight of him Linda still
can't explain what happened next
did you know you had run over your
husband no but Todd's blood was found on
the bumper and the undercarriage of the
van when emergency medical technicians
arrived they tried to save Todd and they
said they couldn't hook up a
defibrillator to it it was too badly
burned firefighters found him
unresponsive outside the home on county
road 215 he died of smoke inhalation and
thermal injuries Linda and Todd's Dermer
sons Trevor and Trenton what do you
believe happened
our mother murdered our Father she
drugged him and she set the house on
fire
doused him in gasoline then after the
fact when he managed to get out of the
house she uh ran him over with her van
did you have anything to do with his
death nothing whatsoever you must know
Linder that it's very difficult for
people to believe that your husband is
burned in a fire he escapes he's still
alive badly burned and then you hit him
with a car you just happen to have that
kind of bad luck bad luck doesn't even
describe it
Wow and Erin Moriarty joins us at the
table if she did do it she's a really
good actress Erin I think you'll be
surprised that this is actually not who
done it really did it happen at all
because really the question here is was
there a murder or was this really just a
series of terrible accidents that's what
she says the problem is and there's
nothing really to connect her to the
arson and arson is a very tough crime to
prove anyway but I believe that if her
marriage had been perfect she might not
have even been tried at all it's just
the fact her own actions made her look
so suspicious yeah clearly some divide
there in the family as well with the
sons and and her but I've never seen
that before where I went to talk to the
daughters about their mother and then
talk to the sons and I thought I was
talking about two different people yeah
well all right Erin Moriarty thank you
very much and you can see Erin's full
report the death of Todd Sturmer that's
tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00 central
here on CBS